according to Okanagan legend each
colored pool has a unique medical power
there's 365 circled here in this lake
each circle has a different healing
property to it so if you have warts you
might go to one to heal and if you have
a body ache or another ailment you might
go to another among the many unusual
features of this lake is the topography
how it lies in the landscape the key to
this lake is that it's a lake that
really doesn't have any outflow even in
terms of groundwater it's the water that
gets into this thing stays put what's
unusual about this lake is that there
are no streams flowing into it and there
are no streams flowing out of it the
lake lies at the bottom of a sealed
hollow basin normally the water cycle
goes from the hills into streams and
rivers into the ocean but because it's a
closed system in the Canadian Rockies
the meltwater from the snowpack and the
winter runs down the hills picking up
salt all the way into the lagoon but
there's nowhere for the water to go
except for through evaporation when in
high summer most of the water evaporates
it leaves behind Martian style
multicolored intensely saline brine
pools so the reason they're different
colors is because they've got different
concentrations and mixtures of salts
when the water runs off of a particular
part of the hill maybe there's a gypsum
salt and it pulls a lot of that gypsum
salt into one of the ponds and another
part of the hill has a different kind of
mineral salt and that'll pull it into a
different pod the water found in each
pool retains a distinctive mineral
profile some pools coronis learns
contain epsom salts which treat
rheumatism and arthritis for okanagan
healers the color of each pool indicates
which mineral is present First Nations
doctors would have actually used them as
a prescription pad but this isn't the
most surprising thing about spotted Lake
the waters here have among the highest
concentrations of sulfates anywhere in
the world it's like a chunk of Mars has
somehow broken off and traveled 33
million miles and what's exciting is
that scientists believe this Martian
type Lake could contain Martian type
life analysis of water from spotted Lake
revealed that tiny organisms are indeed
living in the pools
it's like Mars has come to earth and in
these weird holes are clues to life on
the Red Planet it's possible that some
kind of life like that might be existing
on Mars which would be an insane
discovery